hi
thanks for coming
uh my name is mark rendall you may
remember me from stupidity last night
uh
there may be more stupidity in the last
talk of the day which we back in here um
where we talk about
some really really bad mistakes that
people have made in programming but this
is my sensible talk they make me do a
sensible talk as well
so this is about writing code that
writes code with roslyn
and uh we'll look at how roslyn works
what the different bits of it are and
then at the end i'll show you how to do
something actually useful with it and
create an analyzer and code fix that
works inside visual studio
so roslyn
basically it's where those red squiggles
and green squiggles under your code come
from it's a lot more than that it's it's
the thing that compiles c sharp code
into msil and then that gets passed on
to the jit that turns it into native
code but when microsoft rewrote the
c-sharp compiler for c-sharp six before
that it had been written in c plus
and
one of the sort of key milestones for
any programming language is that the
compiler for the language should be
written in the language and so with
c-sharp 6 microsoft said we're going to
rewrite the c-sharp compiler in c-sharp
and the vb.net team said we're going to
rewrite the vb.net compiler in vb.net
which serves them right
um
so yes but they didn't just make a
compiler they made a compiler as a
service they made a compiler where all
the parts of it are open and public and
you can use them in your own code
and it's brilliant and
around the time of net's 3.net call 3.1
microsoft said we're not supporting wcf
in net core
or web forms or a couple of other things
uh if it's not in now it's not coming at
all and wcf people went hang on what are
we supposed to do and microsoft said
rewrite it to grpc
and the wca that's that sounds really
complicated and i thought well hang on
you've got in wcf you've got service
contracts and you've got data contracts
and you've got operation contracts
and
those map pretty clearly to grpc
services and rpc methods and messages
and so if you analyze the c-sharp code
which has got the wcf attributes on it
you should be able to generate the grpc
assets that you need
and if roslyn hadn't existed and if step
one of that had been right ac sharp
passer i would have gone but that sounds
really complicated but roslyn existed
and i went that sounds like the kind of
thing that roslyn's good for so that's
why i picked it up and learned it it's
difficult to learn the documentation is
not great hence this talk
so
how to roslyn
a bunch of nuget packages
all under microsoft code analysis so
you've got
microsoft.codeanalysis.csharp.workspaces
and a workspace lets you load a solution
and then you can work with the code
we also have
microsoft.codanalysis.workspaces.ms
build and that
works at a
at the project level and gives you
solutions and everything else there's a
weird little package called
microsoft.build.locator
i really don't understand what it does i
just know it exposes one method and you
need to call that method first
and then there's also nuget.project
model which is useful for analyzing
package references and that sort of
thing so workspaces this is the top
level thing
and we have uh an ad hoc workspace so
you can create this in memory and then
you can create a solution add that to it
create projects add them to the solution
it's really good for unit tests and
mucking about and just
trying ideas out then you have the ms
build workspace which is the useful one
and you can actually call build on it
and it will generate dlls and all that
sort of thing
and then specifically when you're
creating visual studio extensions you
have visual studio workspace which has
got a bunch of extra stuff that lets you
interact with visual studio itself
and the workspace looks like this so you
have a workspace
and you can load a solution into the
workspace and you have one active
solution at a time and then a solution
has projects and the projects have
documents so your c-sharp files are
documents and so are your xaml files and
your appsettings.json files and
everything else
and so
i'm going to switch over to code which
involves putting my glasses on because i
am
old
and i can no longer i got lasik and now
i can actually see uh where the apollo
stuff was left on the moon
um
but i can't read my screen
it's it's a good trade-off
it's improved my tennis
and you know
i'm not good at tennis but i'm better
than i was before i got lasik
and that's what i tell my wife when she
complains about me spending four
thousand pounds on lasers
um so yes here we go this is this is my
demo program
and this is this is the thing you get
from that um ms that build locator and
you do this first you do ms build
locator dot register defaults because
your machine has got all kinds of ms
builds all over the place the dotnet sdk
has one visual studio has one all the
other visual studios have one so this
somehow finds the right one i don't know
how it does it it's magic
okay
so then we create a workspace we call ms
build workspace.create
and we set a
boolean to say load the metadata for
referenced projects so we get
all the
new get packages and all those sorts of
things we get metadata loaded for them
we had an event handler to workspace
failed so when it loads the solution it
will actually build it and any build
errors will go out uh to this event
handler and a lot of the time uh like if
you have a net six project and you're
doing this sort of stuff and you try and
load a net framework 4.7 project it
won't work um because it can't run some
of the target dlls that are used by the
main ms build it's very frustrating but
that's the way it is
and then we just open a solution we say
workspace open solution async
args zero
so now we have a solution loaded into
our workspace
and we can go back to the slides and we
do that out do this is all just there
for people to go can we have the slides
so
actually getting into the c-sharp code
we use syntax trees so uh when the
c-sharp compiler runs it tokenizes the
the text
and everything becomes a token so a
semicolon is a token and an open brace
is a token and a string literal is a
token and then it turns that into an
abstract syntax tree and a syntax tree
has syntax nodes in it and so
every bit of your code is represented by
a syntax node and that syntax node has
lots of syntax nodes underneath it and
so on and so on and the entire thing is
represented so you can sort of think of
it like a like a dom or an xml document
but instead of elements it's actually c
sharp code
and you can dig into all of that and
then the tokens are things like
identifiers variable names uh semicolons
white space everything uh is a syntax
token within that tree
um oh no hang on white space is not a
token it's trivia so trivia is stuff
that is there it's important but in
terms of layout and all that kind of
thing but the compiler doesn't care
about it the compiler is going to ignore
it
and
it's really kind of
difficult at first to get your head
around how that syntax tree relates to
actual code and what the syntax type
for like a method call is or a property
declaration is and so there's a super
useful thing
built into visual studio if you've
installed the code
analysis tools as part of your setup
you can go to other windows and syntax
visualizer
and this shows you on the right hand
side a syntax tree
eventually
there we go
and so this is your entire this is
everything in this file so you see we've
got a using directive here that's that
using directive that's an identifier
token we've got the using keyword which
is a token then an identifier named node
and that's got an identifier token in it
and so if you want to find out what a
particular
thing is
then you can just click on it in your
actual code and see what it's
represented as in the syntax tree this
is how i learned how to use rosslyn
syntax trees was
clicking through wcf code on the left
hand side and just seeing what it was on
the right hand side
so go away don't need you
so how do we navigate through syntax
well there are two ways to do this and
the first one
is or the simplest one
uh for most c-sharp programmers is the
link api uh so in the same ways you can
use link to go through an
x document or x element and you've got
dot elements and
dot attributes and all those sorts of
things you have exactly the same kind of
thing in roslyn and so we can say node
dot descendant nodes which will get all
the nodes below that not child nodes
child nodes just gets the next level
down descendant nodes gets everything
below that in the tree and then if we
want to find say class declarations then
we can say of type class declaration
syntax and we get back an i innumerable
of all the syntax nodes which are
declaring a class
if we want to go back up the syntax tree
then we can use first ancestor or self
so if i want to find what namespace this
class is in i can say first ancestor or
self namespace declaration syntax and
it'll navigate up the tree until it
finds
a syntax of that type and it's super
easy
so i'll show you how that looks in here
we have a syntax querydemo.listasync
so if i navigate to that
we've got our solution here
and we say for each document in solution
dot projects dot select many p documents
uh get the syntax root from the document
if root is null that means it's not a
syntax document so it might be
appsettings.json or uh or just a static
image or whatever it is so we'll get
that null if there's no c-sharp for us
to read
or vb
and then
really nice thing is that it gives you
back the same stuff regardless of
whether it's c-sharp or vb code and very
early on one of the demos was i'm going
to copy this chunk of vb code and then
using roslyn i'm going to paste it over
here as c sharp code and i really don't
understand why everybody in the world
hasn't done that already
i'm going to write a
trojan that infects people's computers
and anytime it signs vb.net code it's
going to rewrite it as c-sharp
and then
charge them a bitcoin ransom to turn it
back
i either pay me 5 000 in bitcoin or just
learn c sharp and get on with it
i didn't say it was going to be
completely serious you know it's it's
it's still me i'm still stupid
um so yes but no we can go through here
and uh you know class declaration syntax
and interface declaration syntax they
have a base type which is a base type
declaration syntax and so we can say
find uh in all the nodes in this
document find type declaration syntaxes
and then we can get the namespace by
doing this first ancestor or self and
then we can put those two things
together and we can just write out the
namespace and the type name and so if i
run this
and hope it can find the solution it's
looking for
are you finding it there we go
it took it a while but it got there so
this this solution contains a class
called program sample.program and
there's a library project which contains
a class called sample.library.greeta
that was exciting wasn't it
okay
so you can go through all your code and
just write these queries these link
queries um and actually that's that's a
very useful way of like searching
through an entire solution looking for
interesting things
but if you actually have a node
you actually have a document and you're
looking for specific things in that
document say method declarations and you
want to make sure that all the method
declarations have got
a public or a private or an internal or
protected you know nobody's just gone
void main
then you can use
an alternative approach which is called
the syntax walker
and there's an important thing that you
have to remember here that i forgot a
couple of times uh early on in my roslyn
journey there is a c-sharp syntax
visitor
and there is a c-sharp syntax walker
the c-sharp syntax visitor
will get a thing and then it will stop
so if you've got a say a method
declaration if you've got a class
declaration and it's got another class
declaration inside it then the c-sharp
syntax visitor won't find that nested
declaration it does it it's kind of like
the difference between child nodes and
descendant nodes c-sharp syntax walker
will just go right through the entire
tree and find all the types you're
looking for and so you inherit from this
c-sharp syntax walker class and you just
override the method for things you are
interested in so if i'm looking for a
class declaration syntax i just override
visit class declaration
so we go back to my demo
and
we comment that out and we uncomment
that
and head over to that definition we have
this list types walker here and we can
just say walker dot visit and pass in
our syntax tree and that types walker
just overrides visit class declaration
and visit interface declaration because
i don't care about structs and enums and
records apparently but those are in
there as well
um and then i can just write that out uh
the same as before so this is a
different
application but it's going to do exactly
the same thing
and it's going to put it down there for
some reason and i don't know why but it
did
so yes we still get the same output out
of that
so
we've now got we've got the syntax and
we've got the identifiers and we can get
the tokens out and so um if i see uh
like a call to logger.log information
um i can sort of go okay so underscore
logger is usually but how do i know what
type underscore logger is and so i could
write code to go and find where
underscore logger is defined and where
everywhere else where it's referenced
and then see if it's passed in as a
parameter to the constructor or is it
being created with a new or or something
like that which is just nobody wants to
have to do all of that and so this is
where roslyn gets really cool it has
this idea of semantic models so you can
say okay i've got my syntax tree
give me
what it means give me a model that tells
me what everything in that syntax tree
means and that gives us something that
looks a lot like doing reflection at
runtime so if you've got a type and
you're doing you do
object.gettype then you can do get
methods and get properties and get
fields and the semantic model gives you
the same kind of functionality but it's
doing it with code that's not running
it's doing it
at design time
and so we can say
await
project.getcompilation async and then
from the compilation we can pass in the
syntax tree that we're using and we can
say give me the semantic model for this
and tell me what all of it means
and then within that we get symbols so
we had syntax nodes in the syntax tree
in the semantic model we have symbols
and there's a there's a method symbol
and a named type symbol
and these look like uh
a lot like method info and type info and
those things that we get from reflection
so back here again
and let's close everything else
and we'll take that out and we'll go and
look at list async
so
for each project in solution.projects
get the compilation now the project
might not be a compilable project the
project might be
one of those weird random projects that
doesn't have any c sharp code in it and
if that's the case then get compilation
async will return null
and then we can say go through the
documents get the syntax tree for the
document and then we can say get
semantic model for that tree so that
gives us the semantic model for that
entire file
and then we can
go looping through our syntax
with our descendant nodes of type base
declaration syntax and then we can go to
the model and say give me the declared
symbol
for this
type declaration syntax
and it will pass it back as an i named
type symbol and i named type symbol
has got
uh a whole bunch of properties
uh so we've got member names and
static constructors and tuple elements
and all these sorts of things and
containing namespace and
attributes everything related to that um
is available
on this uh named type symbol
as immutable arrays a lot there's a lot
of immutability in roslyn and we'll talk
more about that later on
so if it's a named type symbol then we
can just say what type it is which will
be interface or class or struct or
whatever
and then we can put system dot
containing namespace and symbol.name
and so this allows us to go right i've
got i logger and that will give me back
a symbol
and i can say that symbol is a reference
to something and i can say give me the
type information for that symbol and
it'll come back and say that type is i
logger of something or just i logger
or something that implements i logger
and so
once i'm in there i can say uh i've got
my type kind and my containing namespace
but now i can say give me all the
members of that symbol of type method
symbol so give me the declared methods
in that
symbol and the method symbol has a thing
on there that says is it implicitly
declared because by the time we get here
a lot of the c-sharp compilation process
is already run so if you've got a
property the c-sharp compiler generates
get and set methods and hides them
but they will show up here
if you don't have an explicit
constructor it generates a default
constructor for you and that will show
up here so i don't i don't want to see
anything that's implicitly declared
and i can just write
method symbol.name out here
and so if we run that and it'll stay at
the front this time
see now i've got a class which is sample
program and it's got a method main and a
method ask name and i've got a class
which is sample library greeter which
has got a constructor
which just has that special name dot c
tour so it doesn't
doesn't give you the the sort of greeter
name for it and we have a greet method
um
i should probably
actually
let's
uh
oh for goodness sake
show more options
yes windows 11 two clicks are definitely
better than one thanks for that
no i don't trust the authors i'm an
idiot
so yes you can see here we've got sample
here's program here's my main method
here's my ask name method
and you can see in sample library we
have greeter and that
it's not an implicit constructor so it
wasn't implicitly declared and i have my
greet method here and the really great
thing is roslyn by the time i get to
these symbols i don't care whether you
use the lambda syntax for a method or
any of that sort of stuff
i know what it's doing i know what type
it's returning i know all that sort of
good stuff
okay
so
you can do a lot of quite powerful
things with these symbols and syntax
trees and all this sort of stuff and
there's quite a lot of stuff
built into
roslyn that would be difficult to
implement but they've they've done it
for you so for example there is a dot
rename method
in there and if you want to rename a
type and then have that reflected all
through the solution you can just call
dot rename and pass in the new name that
you want to give it and it will actually
give you back a new solution where that
symbol has been renamed and all
references to it have been renamed as
well so it's like having code access to
those cool refactorings that you have in
visual studio itself
and so one of the things we can do is
find
references to types or all the types
that are used by
a a class and so if we
uh
there's a symbol visitor but i'm not
going to show it to you because
um
it takes a lot of time and
personally i've never i don't use it for
anything i always with symbols i just do
get members and and this and that and
the other um but the code for this is on
github uh and
there's a link at the end um and you can
check out what the symbol visitor does
it's
similar to syntax visitor
but it
it works with symbols rather than syntax
trees
the other reason is the last time i did
this talk it took an extra 15 minutes um
so i've set a thing on my watch to go
buzz
so we're just going to go straight to
dependencies demo and list all used
types
so
we have a hash set of string because we
only want to list each type once
and we say for each project in this
solution get the compilation
for each document in project.documents
and then
this is a fun one uh if you're running
over
um
let's say a wpf solution
you have xaml files in your wpf solution
but somewhere hiding in the obj folder
is if you've got a user control called
my flashy button
then you've got a myflashybutton.xml
somewhere hiding in your project there's
a myflashybutton.xml.g
which is the c sharp code that's been
generated from that xaml same thing with
razer
pages in blazer projects and things like
that there's some hidden code being
generated and now particularly we've got
source generators doing stuff you've got
to deal with this idea because we don't
want to be refactoring or rewriting or
raising alerts because
code that's been generated by visual
studio or something has done weird
things
so this does its very best
to work out if the file is auto
generated so we get the file name
without the extension the last extension
because we're assuming that's going to
be
cs and then these are the patterns that
i have found we've got temporary
generated file
dot designer
that will hide any
windows forms sort of automatically
maintain files
dot generated gets in there a lot dot
g hides all your xaml cs files dot gi
i can't remember but i must have found
it because it's in there
and then we also have begins with
auto-generated comment and this shows
actually doing some some code
intelligence stuff
so we can say uh get the leading trivia
for this document so get everything
before
uh an actual c-sharp syntax uh token
which is usually using or possibly
namespace so the leading trivia if
there's comments at the top of the code
it will pick all of those up and we can
say where's
the kind is multi-line comment trivia or
single line comment trivia
and then we can go through those
and we can say get the text of that
comment whatever it might be
and then just look to see if it contains
the word auto generated either hyphened
or not hyphened
because
there's no standard for this
uh
and
yeah and it doesn't pick up some things
because quite a lot of the time the
comment says this code was generated by
a tool
um which to be fair would also be true
of code that
some people i've worked with have
written
okay so if it's auto-generated ignore it
otherwise get the syntax tree so notice
that auto generated just worked on the
file name so we're trying to be as
efficient as possible here because then
if it's if we think it's not auto
generated but it still might be we have
to get the syntax tree which takes like
a few milliseconds um
if that's null then we just carry on
otherwise we get the semantic model
uh we get the
syntax node those should probably be in
the other order
that's that's unnecessary
so yeah there we go get the get the
syntax root of the document
that get root async returns the top
level syntax
uh node
and then we can say does it begin with
an auto generated comment and if it does
then we'll just continue round
otherwise
we'll just say get the semantic model
and then we have this get types
item here and we pass in our syntax node
and our semantic model
and so we say named types we're going to
go through and we're going to look for
identifier name syntax
which is going to be variables
fields properties that sort of thing and
we can look for expressions as well
because in c sharp all expressions have
a type
um and so like uh x equals x plus one
if x is an integer that whole expression
has a type of integer and so we can say
or if you're calling a method then that
has a return type and so that expression
has a type there as well
even if that return type is void
or system.void as it's actually called
and so in here we can say get the named
types
and find the uh named type symbols for
those
get for the identifiers and do the same
thing with the expressions
uh find all the things which are a named
type because some of these things are
not a named type some of them might be
an error type because the compiler
doesn't actually know what they are at
the moment but the syntax tree still has
to work even if your code's broken
and there's also just other i-type
symbol implementations that are things
that are not named types they're they're
sort of magic and they're hidden and
don't touch them and then we can just
concatenate those together
and i should be using symbol equality
comparer when comparing symbols that's
incredibly meta that's the roslin
analyzer analyzer telling me that i've
written my roslin analyzer wrong
and probably offering me a coat there
you go
introduce per no i'm not going to do
that
but yes
and then i can push that back up there
and then we get typeset dot order by
so we do for each name type symbol and
then we just add the uh containing
namespace and name type symbol.name
um interesting point about containing
namespace
uh if you there it has a dot name
property on it
so if you are in
say system.link
then symbol.containingnamespace.name
will be link
and it will have a containing namespace
which is system and then that will have
a containing namespace which is the
global namespace
but if you call to string on containing
mainspace it turns it into system.link
so which is essentially what we're doing
here with string interpolation
so if i run this
we can see that these are all the types
that are used by anything in this
program so it uses my type obviously
sample.library.greater
it's not actually using program anywhere
there's no references to program in any
expressions or identifiers so it doesn't
show that one up but we are using
boolean and char and console in 32 and
string and void system.void which is not
available to us as a type
it is available to f sharp programmers
because they have unit which is
basically the same thing but everything
has a type even if that type is void
okay
then it gets really fun so this is the
point where it's actually starting to do
something useful is when you can rewrite
the code and
it is incredibly straightforward once
you get your head around all of this and
you've learned what the different syntax
node types are called and the different
symbols are called and you've got used
to this idea of spelunking through your
code in a console application
then you can start to rewrite that code
you can start to make tweaks to it
but remember i said all those things in
syntax nodes and and symbols they're all
immutable arrays so there is a
system.collections.immutable
nuget package which was basically
created i've got mads torgeson in the
room by the way so i'm teaching you
about roslyn and the guy is yeah it's
it's a little bit unnerving
oh cool okay i'm just waiting for him to
be looking at me
but yeah i think we're doing all right
so um
system.collections.immutable was
actually created for the roslyn project
because the thing is you've got your
your model of your program in memory and
if two things change that at the same
time
that's bad
but what you don't want is a crapload of
locks or semaphores all over the place
to stop two things because a
that's going to slow things down and b
if you say you should lock something
before you modify it
you're relying on programmers
to actually do that
and
yeah
just know so everything's immutable um
what things in roslyn are immutable
well
everything
solutions are immutable projects are
immutable documents syntax nodes
everything from top to bottom the only
thing that is not immutable is workspace
okay so if you add one letter to one
line in one syntax node in one document
in one project
what you get
is a new solution
because it's immutable and then that
becomes the active solution so every
time you change something it's rebuilt
and obviously you know there's a lot of
reuse going in there not literally
recreating the entire tree every time
you do something but
making a change to a syntax node
affects the solution at the top level
and then you go back to the workspace
and you say apply the changes from this
solution and then that becomes the
current solution
and that makes it really difficult
because if you think about it okay let's
say
i just want to
call to upper on any string literals
anywhere in my application
that's fun we can do that
so
i get my i go to my document and i say
hey document give me all the string
literals in your syntax tree and it says
okay here you go and so i change the
first one and i add two upper to it
and now
the whole of the rest of the tree that
that node is contained in has become
invalidated the document is invalidated
because i made a change and so i need to
kind of go and i do it
and then i apply that
and then i start for reaching through
again and remember which ones i've
already done and then add the next one
it would be horrible and so there is a
c-sharp syntax rewriter which looks just
like the c-sharp syntax walker or
visitor except instead of void every
method returns a syntax node
and so that looks like
this
so up shift all strings we go through we
ignore auto-generated comments um
we also ignore um
so one of the auto-generated files is
in.net
6 projects is assemblyinfo.cs
because we don't put that in anymore
it's auto-generated for us from the cs
proj file and assembly info doesn't like
it if you up shift your assembly
description or assembly company name so
that's why we keep those out like that
and then
we have our model we get our semantic
model for this document
some reason we're not checking to see
whether that's null but never mind and
then we just create a string literal up
shifter and we pass in our semantic
model
and then we say visit and pass in our
syntax root here
and then
if we go and look in here
we can see we just override visit
literal expression
and so any literal expression syntax
that we get in here uh will be will
trigger this method and we can say
is it an i named type symbol and if the
type is string
and
then we could say
uh
is it system.string and assume that it's
got uh two upper invariant but actually
it's just as much fun to say look at its
members and see if it's got a two upper
invariant member on it and then we'll
just call that anyway because if some
idiots come along and created their own
string because microsoft string is
rubbish and they know how to string
better than microsoft
i'm literally working on code written by
somebody who thought that about himself
it's everything is is wrapped in his
weird variants
and so i go this is a string it has a
two upper invariant method and so i'm
going to add a call to dot to upper
invariant to this string here
um and so
i need to return a new syntax node here
and so i can return syntax factory so
when you want to generate code you use
syntax factory that allows you to create
any kind of c-sharp syntax the other
thing you can do is just pass it a
string and say syntax factory.pass
which is often a lot more
straightforward believe me
but i'm going to create an invocation
expression
which is going to use a member access
of this node here so this literal we're
going to access a member on that literal
and we're going to pass in the
identifier name of string.two upper
invariant so we're going to create a
member access expression that accesses a
member to upper invariant on that node
and we just return that back out
so
when this finishes
the top level syntax node that we've
passed in to visit will have had any
string literals they'll have had the two
upper invariant appended onto them
if
uh we don't match any of these things
here then we return base dot visit
literal expression it's always a good
idea with these roslin things to call
the base method a lot of the time if you
don't call the base method it will stop
walking and uh you can have strings
inside strings now thanks to string
interpolation you can have a string
which is an interpolation string and
then inside that you can have a string
literal it's quite often you have sort
of a boolean and you say if this then
that string otherwise that string or
something so you need to dig down into
uh string literals to see if there are
any more string literals hiding inside
them
this is one of those things we i kind of
go that's complicated imagine having to
write
that imagine to write this i cannot
begin to imagine um how you go about
writing one of these things
super clever people at work
okay so then that comes back to here
um and we say visit and we get a new
route out of that so that's the top
level syntax node with any of those
rewrites those changes made all the way
through it
and we just have a new top level node
now
and then we can call is equivalent to
and so we say new root dot is equivalent
to
root is it
the same document you could strip all
the white space out and it would be
semantically the same document
so we use this is equivalent to to say
have we actually changed anything
and if we have
let's count how many things we've
changed and we'll say solution equals
new solution
with document syntax root
so every document every project every
solution has an id which is actually a
good but it's wrapped in a document id
struct
and we say so create a new solution and
this document should now have this
syntax route
so it automatically handles the thing
about the project so it creates a new
document with that syntax route and a
new project with that document and a new
solution with that project that's been
changed and it throws away the old ones
because they're immutable
and then we store that in here and we
keep going through and we keep going
through
and then down at the end here we just
say uh if new solution and workspace dot
current solution are not the same then
workspace dot try apply changes i'm not
doing anything
with the return of that but try apply
changes returns boolean and so if your
new solution
contains changes but somebody else has
changed current solution in the meantime
this is like doing a git merge it's like
a conflict thing so something else has
changed workspace.current solution in
the meantime then no you can't do this
start again with current solution and go
back and try again so i could put
something like if not workspace dot try
apply changes
go to
here
and i'm not afraid of go to's
there you go there's a label
and we can say if not workspace
screw you dykstra
i love goto
um
i
go to is is much maligned and and i
don't appreciate it
i write quite a lot of methods which are
try and they return boolean and they
have an out parameter
um and
you try three or four things along the
way to doing it you're going can i do
this okay i did that and if at any point
any of those fail you have to set that
parameter default and return false so
you've got two operations and so you can
either say if i can't do this thing
equals default return false if i can't
do this thing equals default return
false or you can nest your riffs and go
if this if that if that if that
value equals this return true and then
do or you can put thing equals default
return false down at the bottom
with an abort label and then in all your
ifs you just do go to abort go to a port
go to a ball so yeah i like go to
also i'm just contrary
so
we've got our sample here we've got a
string literal in here says hello name
um if we've got a string literal in here
we've got what's oh hang on we'll take
that two upper invariant off there
so that
is now back to where it should be
and if we run this
one change is applied
and then if i go back to code here it's
not in there because it's probably
what's my debug set to
solution explorer
properties
debug
oh good lord
they changed everything oh okay there we
go
copenhagen
all right cool
yes right 15 minutes and we're just
about to move to the analyzer which is
the really good bit so let's run this
again against the right code
and we see one change is applied
and
if we go back to here to upper invariant
has magically appeared on there what you
will notice is that it has not appeared
on here because this
is not a string literal it is an
interpolated string expression and it's
a different thing and so if i wanted to
catch that i would have to add an
override for that in my syntax rewriter
as well
so yes
you can do syntax node.replace node and
for very quick fixes and we will
actually see this in a moment
that is a valid way of doing things but
if you think you're going to do multiple
replacements on a single node then
c-sharp syntax rewriter is your friend
remember to call base
syntax factory for generating code just
type syntax factory dot and marvel at
the many different kinds of syntax that
there are and then use pass and just
pass in some code in a string
and then solution.with document syntax
root creates a new copy of the solution
and then workspace workspace dot try
apply changes and if that returns false
you have to use a go to
no not not allowed to do anything else
okay
so the point at which this actually
becomes useful for most people is
analyzers rosalind analyzers are
fantastic and there are uh two things
that i really really like about them
and one
is that
uh they do a lot of the hard work for
you
and you just tell the analyzer what kind
of things you're interested in and then
it just calls you and says hey i've got
one of these is it okay and you can say
yes it is or you can return some
diagnostics and say there's a problem
with it but you can also create a code
fix for it that magically fixes whatever
it is
and the other thing i really like about
them is the deployment model so you can
create a visual studio extension
uh with your analyzer or analyzers in it
and then people can download that from
the visual studio marketplace
and so you know these days code rush
from devexpress that's pretty much what
that is it's a bunch of roslin analyzers
resharpers still use their code engine
of their own
because
you know they've got it and why not
carry on using it
the other place you can put it is in the
nuget package and so if you put out a
nuget package an x unit is a good
example of this so when you install x
unit it brings some analyzers with it
and then if you do uh if you create a
test method
and you put theory attribute on it
and you put an inline data attribute on
it and your method takes two parameters
but your inline data attribute doesn't
have two parameters you'll get squiggles
saying that's not going to work your
inline data doesn't match your theory
and this is distributed so you don't
have to install an extension in visual
studio to do this
you can just ship it with your nuget
package and it has the fix in there if
it's possible to to intelligently fix it
so
we're just going to create a very simple
logger usage analyzer ilogger so
everybody uses ilogger in your.net
core mvc
applications all that sort of thing and
you just go underscore logger dot log
information bar
which shouldn't that's not right that's
bad what you should do
is if underscore logger dot is enabled
log level information then underscore
logger.log information bar
but
programmers
are lazy
and so we don't and so we just make that
log information call and then inside
there it says yeah i just don't do that
and all this sort of stuff
and quite a lot of the time in that log
thing we might be calling another method
we might be accessing a property we're
doing things it's a non-zero effort to
call that logger and particularly if
you've got like underscore logger dot
log debug
that's almost certainly not turned on in
production but it's still taking up cpu
cycles
so if you look at code
inside kestrel for example where they're
trying to squeeze every last request per
second
all the loggers calls
are guarded with if underscore logger
dot is enabled what would be really nice
is if we could find
this
and automatically replace it with this
so
10 minutes to go i'm not going to write
it live
but
i was saying to mads at lunch time
the version last time i did this was for
visual studio 2019 now on 2022 it
doesn't work and so i thought i'll i'll
just write it again from scratch in
2022. it took me one hour to write this
and obviously you know i know
roslyn and i've done a lot of stuff with
it but
so we create
um
in the visual studio project templates
you will find analyzer with code fix
and that will generate you um
essentially a bunch of projects and in
that project you will have your logger
fix
and your loggerfix.codefixes
logofix is the name i gave the project
we have a package here which is when you
want to bundle it as a nuget package and
distribute it
it generates tests for us which i
haven't done anything with and we have a
vsix if you want to bundle it up and
package it and ship it to the visual
studio marketplace
or if you want to write a joke extension
and then when your friend goes away and
leaves his machine unlocked you sneak on
and you copy the vsix package on and
then weird things start happening in his
code and he doesn't know why
just little red squiggles under every
third line of code going you're just a
bad person
[Laughter]
words just come out of my mouth
anyway
so we have a diagnostic analyzer based
class that's how we implement our
analyzer and we're going to override
things on there so we give ourselves a
diagnostic id we're just going to call
ourselves logger
we have some localizable strings because
we want to tell our friend he's a bad
person in all the languages in the world
using google translate so we have our
resources file so we can localize our
messages and uh menu items and things so
we have a title and a message format and
a description uh the category shouldn't
be naming the category should be
writing
proper
code
so yeah
we have a
override supported diagnostics and we're
going to return an immutable array of
rule here so our diagnostic descriptor
this is our rule that our analyzer is
checking for which has got our id and
our title and message format and our
category
if i was actually doing this i would try
and figure out what the category should
be because there are some pre-named ones
so that's our supported diagnostic so we
can basically say if you have anything
that matches this diagnostic then
call us we have this initialize which
gives us the analysis context
and that
allows us to register our operation in
there
we're going to register analyze
operation here and the things that we
are operating on is invocations because
underscore logger dot log something is a
method
invocation and then we have our analyze
operation here
and we go okay so this is passing in
essentially semantic model things at
this point and so we have our context
operation that's just i operation we
want to say is it an invocation
operation is it are we invoking a method
and if we are then we can say okay is
the target method a log method and so we
can say here um
log methods dot contains so log methods
is up here log critical debug error
information trace and warning i'm not
dealing with the
dot log open brackets log level
information because a it's really
complicated
and b who uses that
hands up who uses that
good
thank you
so yeah is log just goes
does log methods contain that name
and then
is it ilogger and then down here so we
pass in the type that the method is
being invoked on and it's either going
to be ilogger but actually it's not it's
an extension method
it's uh in a
type called logging extensions
um
and so we have logger extensions sorry
here and then we say is it
microsoft.extensions.logging
and we go okay so is the namespace
logging and is that contained in the
extensions namespace and is that
contained in the microsoft namespace and
is that in the global namespace if all
that is true then this is definitely
microsoft's log information or log debug
method
and then we can say is it guarded we can
go looking to say
is this invocation guarded
so we say go
oh
this is a fun for loop
if you've never written a for loop that
wasn't just for i equals thing i is less
than thing
welcome to
possibly hell i don't know
so
for this is
how you loop back up things in a tree
you say for var parent
and then you say it's not a method or
property declaration if we get to a
method or property declaration there
aren't going to be any if statements
outside of that so we don't care
and then at the end here we can say
parent equals parent or parent
um i get in so much trouble at work for
writing for loops like that
it's perfectly legitimate
then i do go to's to jump out of them
okay
so
we're at the parent of our log method
now and we go is it an if statement if
it isn't an if statement then it's
definitely not an if logger dot is
enabled so we can just carry on and then
we can go back into this
parent here and we can find invocation
expression syntax this isn't quite right
there would be a little bit more to it
than this
and we can say uh get
the operation
here which is an invocation and then we
can say target method name is enabled
return true so
actually what i would also need to do
here is check that that's being called
on the logger type and all this sort of
thing like i say it only took me an hour
and
so yeah then
if it is already guarded we can just
return early otherwise we create a
diagnostic we tell it where we're
talking about saying there's a problem
we tell it the rule that it's broken and
we pass in the invocation target method
dot name and that will be used to format
a message and then we can report this
diagnostic
and so if i run this now it'll spin up a
new visual studio instance with this
analyzer active
and we can open up worker sample here
this does take a minute because it's a
laptop
i need a big ass workstation with like
64 calls or something because i am also
running slack so you know
it gets such a bad rap
and it totally deserves it
right
so here we have an unguarded call
give visual studio a minute to catch up
and actually generate the model in
memory and
pass the syntax and all this sort of
stuff
and
eventually
we should get some squiggles that appear
under here
so you can sort of tell it's getting
there there we go we have a green
squiggle underscore logger dot log
information and if i mouse over that
logger fix log call log information is
not guarded with is enabled and it also
shows up as a warning in my project
compilation down here and it would also
show up as a warning
so if this was a nuget package included
in the project it would then also show
up as a warning in the ci builds
which is another reason for doing it in
nougat packages
and so
the other thing that we have in the
analyzer i'm not going to stop the other
thing running is we have a codefix
provider
and so go away
go away
and so in here this is the thing that
fixes
the problem
and we have this register code fixes
async
and we say
we
work
with
um
declarations of expression statement
syntax so what we want is the whole
underscore loggered the invocation
syntax isn't the whole line the whole
line is underscore logger dot log
information whatever the arguments are
semicolon we want all of that so we're
going to register a code fix for that
and we say here is our create changed
solution
and you can see here and every time you
press ctrl dot or alt enter and apply a
code fix in visual studio the method
that is being called returns a new
solution and then visual studio sets
that as the current solution every time
and so we do this add is enabled guard
async and we return a whole new solution
down here
so we say document get semantic model
async the level well the operation
target method is log whatever and so the
level is the substring of that starting
at the fourth character so third when
you're zero based
then we find the member access
expression so that is the um
the
is
the underscore log level that's that's
the
um invocation thing there the member
access expression it's the syntax node
equivalent of our operation that we've
got up here so that's the semantic model
this is the syntax node
and then we can get the leading trivia
off there and we can create a new is
enabled syntax and remember i said pass
expression
so yeah we just syntax factory.pass
expression source dot is enabled log
level level
um and then we use syntax factory to
wrap that in an if statement
and that is constructed by passing in an
if keyword and an open paren token and
then our is enabled expression here and
then a close paren token with trailing
trivia and then we'll put a new line in
there that's white space then we add the
original expression and we put four
spaces on the start of it because i
don't care what your indentation
standards are i'm putting in four spaces
deal with it um and then uh we
don't have an else because we could have
an else there as well and we put back
the leading trivia that we got from the
original expression okay
easy
um
now we do original solution is
document.project.solution
we get the syntax root from our document
we do syntax root.replacenode and we
replace our expression node here so we
don't need a visitor in this case we're
just replacing one node and we replace
that with our if statement and then we
return
the original solution with this new
document syntax root and that is our
code fix and so if in here i press
control dot
it and say add is enabled guard
then i get my is enabled goes in there
and
the code is indented and the squiggle
has gone away because now things are
being done properly and that is how you
write a roslin analyzer see easy
it is it is it's easy it's honestly um
the first one will take you like a few
hours and then the second one you'll
copy and paste most of the code from the
first one
and it will it'll go much quicker once
you get past that kind of initial i need
to get my head around this and i hope
i've helped you with that to a certain
extent and certainly shown you how easy
it is
and if you're sitting here thinking it's
really complicated like i say imagine
actually writing a c sharp passer from
scratch
so you know diagnostic analyzer which
makes the squiggles and your code fix
provider that fixes the squiggles it
takes care of all the loading the
solution and all that sort of stuff for
you here are some useful
resources so josh varti when i was
learning this stuff originally he wrote
a series of blog posts they are
fantastic um they're slightly out of
date they don't have all the latest
c-sharp stuff but
it's the fundamentals it's the basics
and it's still pretty valid
on
github.com.net analyzers it's an
organization and there's a bunch of real
world examples on there that you can
steal from
and if you're interested in a thing that
automatically migrates wcf to grpc then
check out visual recode
because that's what it tries to do
that's it thank you very much couple
minutes over
but cheers
you